let's welcome tonight's guests he looks
like a car salesman and smells like an
air freshener co-host of fox and Fred's
first Tod
pyro don't let the accent fool you she's
here to school you co-host of the bottom
line on Fox Business D
McDow he knows eight ways to kill a man
with a paperclip nine if it's Rusty
former CIA operative and host of the
president's daily brief podcast Mike
Baker and if walls could talk her office
would be in witness protection New York
Times bestselling author and Fox new
contributor
cat all right well that's about it for
me before we get to some new stories
let's do
this Greg's
leftovers M yeah leftovers where I read
the jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck we'll staple Joe Macky
to a wall and use his head as a
dartboard earlier this week the White
House unveiled its 2023 holiday
decorations and while of course there
are no stockings for President Biden's
grandchildren there is one for Joe's
Living
Nurse she's Caribbean
not that that matters meanwhile the
family does plan to still leave out
cookies and milk for Santa and a woman's
wig for no one in
particular a retired Health official
says the Chinese government may have
killed a pandemic researcher by throwing
him off the Wuhan lab roof or as the CDC
calls it a typical covid related
death Chicago mayor Brandon Johnson is
blaming his City's problems on
right-wing
extremism not surprising as it is maggot
country in a new interview France's
first lady opened up about dating French
president Emanuel macron while he was
her student when he was 15 and she was
40 so take notes kids if your teacher
wants to bang you you too could become
president see they always say it's a bad
thing well Todd pyro says it's a good
thing but I say it's a bad thing a pack
of Canadian super pigs may reportedly
soon cross the border into the United
States apparently it's payback for the
ones we once sent to
[Applause]
Canada the FDA has approved an atome
test for
chyia here's how it works if you have
sex with Hunter Biden you have
cdia that's really not an atome test all
right '90s boy band New Kids on the
Block have announced they're going on a
2024 tour although they've since changed
their name to old guys at The
Villages according to a new study women
have more regret anxiety and depressing
thoughts after sex than men do
especially if they have it with the
wrong person I knew that was coming I
saw that coming a mile
away a new survey says that 43% of
Americans are frequently constipated God
don't come back to me Greg the other 57%
eat at Taco
Bell and finally a new study claims that
Prehistoric Women were better at hunting
than men wow I didn't even know they had
shoe stores back
[Laughter]
then
now to the news Elon leaves no doubt
that he won't sell out yes it's time
for it's coming your way hey hey it's
video of the
day today's video of the day it comes to
us from a New York Times conference this
week when Elon Musk addressed the
Cowardly advertisers that are leaving X
like Joy bear when the prune juice hits
watch and learn how it's
done there's a public perception that
that was part of a apology tour if you
will that this had been said online
there was all of the criticism there was
advertisers leaving we talked to Bob
Iger stop you hope uh don't advertise
you don't want them to advertise no what
do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go yourself
but go
yourself is that
clear I hope it is hey Bob here in the
audience wow he really has it in for
Bob but which Bob this
one this
one it's Bob
Marley or this
one
of course it was a shout out to Bob Iger
the CEO of the Disney disaster which is
one of the companies that ditched X Elon
was also given another opportunity to
walk this back but did
he how do you think then about the
economics of of x if if if if part of
the underlying model at least today and
maybe it needs to shift maybe the answer
is in needs to shift away from
advertising um if if you believe that
this is the one part of your business
where you will be beholden to those who
uh have this
view G what do you do f
y g
f
y what could that stand
for gutfeld's freaking
yummy but he's got a point how insane is
it that companies are trying to
Blackmail the world's richest man with
money
that's like extorting Jerry Nadler with
salad or blackmailing sports fans by
threatening to cancel
PBS the fact is musk may be the last man
standing between real freedom of speech
and the suffocating block of the
censorship industrial complex which is
made up of government media and Tech
forces he realizes that advertisers have
no spine and can be easily cowed by by
special interest groups in cahoots with
political allies if you don't believe me
I got two words for you Tucker
Carlson
wow look at that room all right Todd uh
your mother called me this morning and
asked me a favor to have you seated in
the first chair so here you are so you
have to be on good behavior understood
you know you've got a thing for my mom
ever since she was here in those seats
right over there yes you mentioned her
every occasion it's kind of weird yeah
maybe I'm like President
macron you know the funny thing is Todd
your mom and I were talking about that
very thing oh come on my God leave
Maryann alone she just had hip
surgery I don't want to know why she had
his surgery
Banker my dad's watching
too hello Mr poor
Maryanne where's the professor anyway so
this has been a fight that has been
going on for years if you don't do what
we say we will kill your business but
it's not the advertisers that are doing
it it's these front leftwing front
groups that are scaring these
advertisers to run away so they
capitalize on the moral cowardice of
advertisers and eline's basically saying
is okay you do this to us let's see how
the Earth handles this right yeah and
that's one of the best things about
having Fu money you get to tell people f
you what this is and so it's so great
for free speech and we thought when he
purchased this thing Free Speech would
be saved it obviously has taking a lot
of hits because they're coming after him
full bore and the Bobby mentioned I know
he's mentioning Bob Iger what I love
about that yeah Bob Iger may be fine
when it comes to his theme parks because
they cost a lot of money to go to and
people go to them but take a look at the
latest Disney movie not doing very well
he could get all the eyeballs and all
the either free advertising on X or real
adver ising on X that he can get also a
lot of his TV properties utilize X to
drive viewership so before he says you
know F you to uh to Mr Twitter over
there Mr X he better realize he should
wake up and ultimately at the end of the
day Elon Musk I think is making a key
Point here so go Elon yeah you know uh
Dean he said uh well let's see what
Earth thinks he's basically banking on
public opinion the fact that we
are addicted to Twitter and we're
addicted to X and we now use it it's
like a hive mind he knows that this
thing is going to survive no matter what
and we completely rely on it and him to
keep speech free but he is also with
telling the CEOs to go um pound dirt I'm
being trying to be a lady good luck with
that uh he's also playing on the petty
jealousy of these CEO M so Bob Iger runs
a company that has told generations of
young women that the only path to
prosperity and happiness is getting our
mitts on some hmbo Prince and then
hanging on for dear life that's Bob
iger's job David Zaza who runs Warner
Brothers Discovery took on $ 55 billion
doll in debt to buy a company that
included
CNN and so and that Max uh dreaming port
hole is a total suckhole yeah so what
does Elon Musk run he runs a brand new
car company that just came out with a
truck it looks like a DeLorean pickup it
looks like it was carred with laser
shooting out of his hands and then he
also he also has a rocket company what
man on the planet doesn't want to own a
rocket company where they can shoot
penises into the
sky I
didn't I didn't see that last part
coming yeah you know uh but you have a
point there he also owns the boring
company do you know what that is
underground tunnels he makes you know
the thing is this is what Mike a the
richest man in the world should be doing
right and I I and I just love how he he
basically in one sentence kind of
humiliated them going like you're trying
to Blackmail me with money like do you
not realize I have more money than
everybody yeah you know uh you could
also make a penis joke about the boring
company yeah right so cuz you know
tunnels and all right
miky I put him over there cuz I figured
he'd behave well oh you put me over here
this the first time the cat I yeah we
get to sit next to each other for the
very first time and thank you by the way
for pointing out who Bob Marley Is that
was very helpful I like that or this Bob
that's Bob Marley um so uh yeah look I I
agree with with with Dean 100% on the
fact that that you know go Elon Musk
right this is this is what you you count
on him for because he does have the the
juice right it's like with Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan's the same way he's got the money
to tell people they tried to cancel him
right they TR they got all outraged over
his his Co perspective and the next
thing you know you've got Joanie Mitchel
or or Neil Young or whomever you know
some 120y old you know pop singer saying
I'm taking my money and going off of
spotify and people are saying you're
still alive you know and so having that
level of cash and I speak also from
experience I I'm the same way really oh
yes the money money that I sit on daily
it's it's it's crazy yes it's crazy and
when advertisers threaten to leave you
Mike you just have them disappear I just
fly another penis right into
space that's what I do with myself yeah
I don't know why why all right cat
imagine you run the cat net Network or
the cat social platform would you uh how
would you deal with advertisers trying
to pressure you on content would you
listen to them or would you listen to
the
users well here's the thing this is why
I don't understand people say money
can't buy
happiness do you not know how happy it
makes you feel to tell someone to go
them
yeah it's one of the best feelings in
the whole entire world yeah and and I
think that for him he has no choice
because he bought this platform because
he wanted to stand against that so he I
don't know how he would be able to deal
with it even if he didn't have all the
money that he has but also I think one
of the issues with Elon is what he puts
himself out there a lot he likes to just
sit on Twitter and just Tweet stuff that
comes into his head so I think that's
part of the reason people are so upset
by him because if there were other CEOs
of things doing that I think that we
might find that not all of their
thoughts were acceptable according to
people who think of things that sort of
way you know the thing is there's
there's a a really good thing that's
happening and a sad thing the good thing
is is that he took the toy out of the
left's hands right they could use
Twitter pre Elon to cancel anybody out
and then when he added Community notes
now you you know a a rumor can't amplify
like it did with Covington and instead
it implodes because the community notes
comes out and hits it but the sad thing
about it is we're beginning to realize
that the only people with real freedom
of speech are people with billions of
dollars what about the rest of us and
that was my point is that like you know
if you if you are beholden to
advertisers you could be gone I take
Market risk every time I open my mouth
that is true we all do when you open
your
mouth oh that means you think I'm an
integral part of the show that is
correct is that what I said what it all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else